another day and democrats are burning
down another city
this time kenosha wisconsin and the
violence has become so radical
that cops are now being knocked
unconscious being left in the ground
after being hit
with bricks used car dealerships are
being burned to the ground
because used cars apparently are tools
of white supremacy or something like
that
and stores are being smashed and smashed
and looted and vandalized all in the
name
of social justice but this is not about
white supremacy or police brutality what
this is really about
is democrats burning down another city
to try to win
an election we'll go all the way down
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from
kai jukebox who said michael i'm 17
and i'm taking sociology at the local
community college this semester
we're already talking about marx the
show has helped me stay
sane in this indoctrination station the
past
three semesters thank you i'm more than
happy i'm so glad
to be a counterbalance to your sociology
professor sociology of course one of the
most left-wing
fields it's hard to even call it an
academic discipline but it goes very far
left
the problem by the way is not reading
marks the problem is that presumably
you're not being taught to understand
marx you should read marx because marx
is a very important thinker in the
history of western thought but you got
to make sure that you understand marx a
great book
to help you understand marx by the way
is one that i just wrote the forward to
just came out a couple weeks ago called
the devil and karl marx
by paul kanger check that one out
actually if you read that book i think
you'll be able to
look around america today and and start
to make sense of everything that's
happening as another city
goes up in flames uh which we will get
to this is all based on another
officer involved shooting uh the story
that you're being presented by the
mainstream media
is very very very different from the
reality of what actually happened we'll
get to that in one second first though
gotta thank our friends over at rock
auto you know me
you know that i don't know anything
about cars and yet i've had some car
trouble in my life
so you your car has some trouble you go
into the brick and mortar store
you say yeah i need the who's he what's
this for the what you might call it
and they say okay well yeah we don't
have your part in stock but
we're going to go online and order it
they probably go to rockauto.com but
they charge you double anyway
and it's all very complicated it's not
very nice that's why i love rock
auto dot com so rock auto is a family
company
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
20 years that's like the entire history
of the internet
the thing i especially love about rock
auto first of all always reliably low
prices
so it's not like you've got a game it's
okay i'm going to buy this part on a
tuesday but
you know on thursday the price is going
to go back up now it's just reliably low
the other thing i love is their catalog
is so simple
that even i can understand it that which
is uh that's a high bar
right now go to rockauto.com see all the
parts
available for your car or truck and then
most important of all
write knowles in the how did you hear
about us box then they will know that we
sent you and that that would be terrific
but head on over there these guys i
really trust them
they're they're always reliable and most
important
so simple even i can do it democrats are
burning down another city
i think today if i didn't want to write
another show today sometimes writing the
show
takes a little bit of time i could have
just gone back to a show from a couple
of weeks ago
and switched the names of the cities
what was the last city they were burning
down i don't know atlanta or whatever
burning down it seems like a different
city every week i could have dubbed in
kenosha wisconsin this the same exact
script
would have remained exactly the same
what happened uh a
man named jacob blake in kenosha was
filmed
uh walking away from the cops with guns
uh
maybe you've seen the clip you got the
cops who have got their guns trained on
guys walking away opens this car door
reaches into his car
as the cops are telling him not to and
then the cops fire on the guy
as he's reaching into his car
raises some questions if you are
for whatever reason under arrest and
you're resisting arrest
that is going to make this a very
provocative and dangerous situation
and in virtually maybe every single one
of these officer-involved killing cases
you've got the perpetrator resisting
arrest which automatically makes things
more dangerous
but then imagine you've got multiple
guns trained on you cop saying stop stop
don't go to her
and you're walking around cool as a
cucumber like you're just gonna walk to
that car
by the way this guy's children were in
the car so you're making this very
dangerous situation for your children
and then he reaches into the car what's
he reaching in to get
we don't know problem is the cops didn't
know either
is he reaching in to grab a gun i don't
know it seems like a very plausible
situation
and so the cops at the very last moment
fire their weapons because what are they
supposed to do are you
if you're a cop or and you you've got
this guy resisting arrest
walks in reaches into his car are you
supposed to wait for him to grab a gun
and turn around and point at you and
fire it off a few times
before you use force probably not
what are you going to do are you going
to shoot him in the ankle and say okay
well i've wounded you now you've learned
your lesson
no that's not how it works if you're at
the point where you've got to discharge
your weapon
you're going to shoot to kill by the way
i don't think this guy
is dead i think he's in a serious
condition but i don't think they ended
up killing him
so you've heard the clip you've seen the
clip
you've looked at what's happened what is
the news saying about this
i'm going to skim through this very
quickly this is the chicago tribune
and this coverage is typical of how the
mainstream media are covering the
the story jacob blake shot by police
officer in kenosha
part of evanston family long associated
with community
activism community activism what does
that mean
the story opens with 554 words
about this guy i'll just give you some
of the highlights jacob blake who was
shot by police officer kenosha on sunday
grew up in evanston as part of a family
with deep ties to local community
activism then it describes the video
but it doesn't describe it too
specifically it says there's unrest
you know now that's that's going on
unrest is code word for people are
burning down
car dealerships and looting and throwing
bricks at cops heads
it describes the video a little bit more
but not too specifically
as of monday blake was in serious
condition blake's family's
been active in and around evanston for
generations said his uncle
justin blake while on route to the
hospital where jacob blake is being
treated
he's a lively young man he's like his
father my brother
justin blake said so one thing you
notice about the article the only source
they ever refer to is this guy's
uncle justin blake said that he's got a
hell of a personality and he loves
people
he moved to the kenosha racine area a
few years ago for a job and family his
uncle said
it was a safer location he could work
and try to save and build for a better
life justin blake said so how many times
is going to say the uncle said this the
uncle said that uh
journalists used to go out and and uh
get multiple sources
and try to construct the story
themselves not allow people who are the
object of the story and their relatives
to write the story he loves sports
music and architecture played football
and basketball at evanston township high
school
why what does any of this have to do
with the story but jacob blake didn't
forget his roots and he returned often
to volunteer with his uncle
at black urban recycling in chicago an
organization that collects aluminum cans
from senior centers
veterans groups and elsewhere to recycle
them and raise money for a community
center
in the inglewood neighborhood justin
blake said man this guy sounds like the
greatest guy on earth right
why on earth would the cops shoot this
guy why were they even there
oh my god this is a setup this is white
supremacy this is police brutality it
has to be right
that's the picture the mainstream media
are painting the veterans
love it when he comes around because
he's always polite and perky
his uncle said man his uncle's sure got
a lot to say jacob blake's grandfather
also named jacob blake served as pastor
of ebenezer ame church in evanston
and was a local leader in the civil
rights movement according to chicago
tribune archives
after the death of martin luther king jr
the reverend jacob blake helped organize
and spoke to a crowd of 3 000 evanston
residents who marched in support of a
local
comprehensive housing law man this guy's
like martin luther king jr for goodness
sakes
can you believe these white supremacist
racist cops did this
for with no reason no provocation
whatsoever it goes on
for like another 150 or 200 words
talk talks about these various buildings
that we're trying to get people out of
the slums
these all this wonderful work that this
man's family's done
542 words later court records show blake
has a pending criminal case that started
last month
online court records indicate kenosha
county prosecutors charge blake
on july 6 with third-degree sexual
assault
trespassing and disorderly conduct in
connection with domestic abuse
an arrest warrant was issued for blake
the next day
huh oh so it doesn't sound
like all that stuff that the uncle said
and how he's wonderful and i was always
helping old ladies cross the street now
he's picking up trash
and litter and aluminum cans maybe
that's not the story
maybe the story is there's a warrant out
for his arrest
because of sexual assault trespassing
and domestic abuse
and it's not that the media completely
ignore it it's not that the media
completely lie about it it's that they
bury
the actual the only actual news the only
relevant information in that story
they bury it almost 550 words into the
story
most articles on the internet by the way
are fewer than 550 words so you'd read a
whole story's worth
before you'd get to any relevant
information there it is you probably
probably haven't heard that information
if you're watching the mainstream media
to hear about this case so what
are the democrats saying joe biden
kamala harris some of the local
the local elected democrats we'll get
into that because they're certainly not
focusing
on the relevant aspects of that case
first though i got to thank our friends
over at paint your life
paintyourlife.com man this what an
amazing service this is so you know i
ordered one of these uh maybe
two years ago for my stepbrother what is
paint your life you upload a photo
they get one of their world-class
artists to make an actual oil painting
or any any other kind of painting too i
just happen to like the oil
they do this beautiful painting out of
it you're working with the artist every
step of the way you get to see proofs
they do a great job framing also
and and you get it i was skeptical that
this could possibly look good
then i get my stepbrothers and i think
oh my gosh i'm so envious
why didn't i get one for me so i just
did it i just did one
for a relative of mine who died when i
was young
and i you know thinking about my home
future generations of noses i really
want people
to be able to know this relative you
know so
what more special way than to have a
portrait painted uh
i i just uploaded that i'm waiting for
it now or working with the artist
it's just terrific it's wonderful it can
be a deceased relative a loved relative
who's still alive a pet a favorite place
anything these guys are the best plea so
you've got it right now uh go to
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting
your money is refunded no big deal
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer you get 20
off your painting 20 off and free
shipping to get the special offer
text the word michael mich ael to sixty
four thousand
that is mich ael to sixty four thousand
michael two sixty four thousand paint
your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
how do you think the democrats the
elected democrats are covering this
shooting
joe biden and kamala harris in a joint
statement yesterday in kenosha wisconsin
jacob blake was shot seven times
in the back as police attempted to
restrain him from getting into his car
his children watched from inside the car
and bystanders watched in disbelief his
children that he walked toward
while he was resisting arrest while he
was reaching into his car
and this morning the nation wakes up yet
again with grief and outrage that
yet another black american is a victim
of excessive force so they're already
saying right now this is this is
excessive force
right in special investigators joe biden
and kamala harris they've already
concluded that forget any other
investigations
this calls for an immediate full and
transparent investigation the officers
must be held accountable
these shots pierce the soul of our
nation
yet another black america we went
through the numbers
how many black americans were killed
unarmed
last year by the police the early number
that came out
we were looking at was nine the highest
number we've seen is 15.
not 9 000 not 15 000
between 9 and 15. and by the way unarmed
does not mean
not dangerous it does not mean that the
shooting was not justified
we're talking about a very very small
number of people in all of the
civilian police encounters throughout
the year this is not
a systemic problem this is not endemic
at all this is completely
as a national political issue contrived
by cynical democrats who want to gin up
racial division and burn down american
cities
they say equal justice has not been real
for black americans and for so many
others
we're at an inflection point we must
dismantle systemic racism
it is an urgent task before us we must
fight to honor the ideals laid in the
original american promise which we are
yet to attain
that all men and women are created equal
but more importantly that they must be
treated equally
this is a complete a complete
misunderstanding
of the american founding first of all
they say we have to dismantle systemic
racism who controls the system
who controls the administrative
government the mainstream media
higher education lower education
hollywood who controls all of it who
controls every
single institution in america democrats
and yet we're supposed to trust them to
dismantle the system that they
preside over and what does it mean the
equality principle all men are created
equal
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
you know you know the thing that
equality principle what does that mean a
lot of people don't understand it
some people deny that it's a
self-evident truth some people
say it hasn't been attained yet actually
that the equality principle
is self-evident in a very technical
logical way
john adams explains this very well it is
a self-evident truth that all men are
created equal
because all men are equally men
a self-evident truth here is something
which contains
the evidence for its truth in itself
and the statement that all men are
created equal is
self-evidently true because we know
looking around that all men
are equally men so that that has been
realized
that's very clearly been realized but
now all
all people have to be treated exactly
equally well what does that mean
should you be treated equally under the
law on the basis of race
yes and you are by the way you are
actually except for the one
aspect of legal racial discrimination
that we have which is called affirmative
action
which disadvantages white and asian
applicants to colleges and it gives
benefit
to hispanic and black applicants to
colleges which the doj office of civil
rights right now is looking into
kind of a side point and certainly not
the narrative that joe biden and kamala
harris are trying to say
they're trying to push what
does this mean in this case
what like what does this case tell us
about the state
of racial relations and equality under
the law nothing
nothing we don't know anything about
this case what we do know
namely that this guy was resisting
arrest he was only shot at the very last
minute when he was reaching into his car
that his kids happened to be in by the
way
and that there was a warrant for his
arrest on sexual assault and domestic
violence
the more evidence we see the more
evidence that this arrest was justified
there's no evidence that i've seen
whatsoever that this is police brutality
white supremacy
any of that nonsense so are joe biden
and kamala harris
lying are they just misguided here or or
are they the third option which is what
i think is true are they
totally cynical do they not care whether
this is
this narrative is true or false do they
just push it because it's a very
effective story in their playbook
this is obviously the latter this is
what they do
this is what they do before elections is
they
gin up completely contrived
racial injustice controversies
and then they burn down cities and they
burn down cities
because they think that this is going to
help them in november
they think that they can only win a
tribal war
they can't win on the field of ideas we
talked about this a little bit yesterday
they can't win
by making logical arguments which is
presupposed by free government
our constitutional system requires that
we make persuasive logical arguments to
one another they know they can't win
that way
they have no argument to make so instead
they've got to burn down cities and get
things
so scary and so tribal that the people
that they believe on the basis of their
tribe are going to vote for them
are going to be encouraged to vote for
them sean king activist with the blm
movement
tweets out that he's not going to call
for peace
he says i'm not going to call for peace
nah we've tried peace for years y'all
don't understand
that language we are calling for a
complete dismantling of american
policing it's not broken
it was built to work this way and mayhem
is the consequence
you earned it you earned it we're going
to burn down your cities we're going to
burn down
and dismantle american policing what do
they mean by policing
do they mean they're going to burn down
one or two bad cops that you can maybe
point to
no they're going to burn down and
they're going to dismantle policing in
general
but policing is a symbol the police are
a symbol
for the american system of law and order
so what he's really saying here is
we're going to dismantle the american
law
we're going to dismantle the american
legal tradition we're going to dismantle
the criminal justice system
and then what's going to happen then we
the radical left
are going to control things that's what
this is all about
i think some squishy conservative types
they'll say okay well look
i'll defend george washington i'll
defend thomas jefferson
but i'm not going to defend the police
everybody hates the police
it's the same thing those are symbols
for the same thing
george washington is a symbol thomas
jefferson is assembled alexander
hamilton james madison
they're symbols of our constitutional
system of our legal framework
of our country you know what the police
are they're symbols of the exact
same thing that is what this is all
about
and we're going back to a position now
where university dorms are being
racially segregated
where people are only shopping at
businesses that
share their their racial tribal
affiliations there's a woman
who was very upset because she went into
a boba tea place boba tea you know boba
tea
it's that tea that has those weird
little balls in it and you kind of it's
kind of nice
anyway it's an it's an asian beverage a
woman walks into this store
which is run by asians and she's very
upset because the boba tea
place is not a black owned business take
a listen
this establishment is uh not black owned
by using you're stealing black culture
is this not black culture trap tea the
boba plug
no your thieves asian asian people
stealing black
black culture once again once again it's
okay you'll be exposed though
you're not black owned you're still in
my
no i came here because i thought it was
black owned that's why i came here to my
friends
i'm supporting a black business this is
not black owned
you're not this is not black owned asian
stealing
black culture once again
don't talk oh my god yeah
i don't want to dance but i guess i'm
tired
okay so it goes on from there i think
you get the idea she's arguing at the
end with this black guy
who says hey lady you're in an asian
joint why are you screaming about
oh it's not a black-owned business and
then she calls him a racial slur because
he doesn't have his tribal solidarity
which the democrats are trying to gin up
because they think it's the only way
they can win the election
i think i'm going to walk into general
sao's chinese chicken palace
and demand that it be become a
sicilian-owned business
why is this chinese joint not sicilian
owned i only eat it sicilian-owned
businesses i probably wouldn't be able
to eat it very many places
if i only went to sicilian-owned
businesses right but one of the nice
things about america is we don't have to
check someone's racial pedigree
before we go in and buy a sandwich or a
cup of iced tea
but that's the point that the left wants
us to get to by the way what does it
mean to be a black owned business
because it's not just this kooky lady
who goes into the shop this is not some
fringe thing
uber eats was giving special privileges
to black-owned businesses you didn't
have to pay a delivery fee
if you aided a black-owned business they
were actually giving out privileges
based on race well you know what if your
business
say has gives equity to five people
and someone who owns one percent of the
business is black
and then the people on the other 99 of
the business are
like the whitest people in the world is
that a black-owned business a black guy
owns part of it how are we gonna do what
if it's a
what if it's a guy who's half black and
half uh
jewish i don't know uh how how is that
going to work how are we going to
plug that into the the racial victimhood
calculator
and figure out exactly how much of that
business we should we should
shop at doesn't make a whole lot of
sense what it boils down to here
what this woman's argument is is that
it's cultural appropriation now
i don't think that boba tea comes from
from africa or from you know the
pla the american plantation before the
civil war or something like that but
she's calling it cultural appropriation
even if the points you were making even
if the premise that boba tea is is
somehow black
even if that were true cultural
appropriation is a very good thing
in fact all culture has to be
appropriated
this is a big lie that the left that
doesn't seem probably they don't
understand because they don't know what
culture is
culture relates to the word cultivation
release the word cult for instance right
you cultivate something in yourself i
was not born loving beethoven
believe it or not even though you know i
don't think my mother ever played baby
beethoven for me now i think some like
bourgeois white mothers do this in the
cities they play beethoven to their
stomachs and they think
their kids are gonna become really smart
and sophisticated this way i did not
have that i was not born
listening to beethoven but i like
beethoven very much why because i
cultivated that taste
i was not born smoking cigars i may as
well have been because i started at an
early age
but i cultivated that taste i cultivated
my appreciation of certain art
cultivated my appreciation of certain
literature i was not born
reading italian is that cultural
appropriation i guess it is but it's
great because now i get to read dante
all cultures is appropriated it's by the
way the premise of
of immigration and assimilation in
america
we have the most open we have a
ridiculously open immigration system in
america
which most people by the way want to
dramatically curtail across racial
groups
but part of the reason we have any
functioning immigration system at all
is based on assimilation that you have
to come in and appropriate the american
culture
and the american cult and you have to
give up some culture too when you do
that
what this woman is saying is no we're
gonna have a pedigree test we're gonna
check your blood
see exactly what percentage black you
are cultural appropriation is really
good who invented pasta
speaking of the italians was it the
italians we actually don't know was it
the italians was it the chinese was it
somewhere in the middle we don't know
we just like it it's good i'm glad now
everybody has pasta
it's cultivating oneself but
we're not allowed to have that we're
moving in the opposite direction
we have a completely degraded culture
and the culture is
decaying more and more by the day and we
have
at the same time coincidentally divvying
up racial groups
so even down in chicago you've got
chicago's mayor lori lightfoot who is
presiding over essentially a failed
state
in america right and this woman is the
machine politician
who's running it she's looking closely
at what's happening in kenosha
that's what that's that's they're
monitoring the situation they're urging
civil and criminal authorities in
kenosha to investigate the incident
i'm so glad that lori lightfoot in
chicago is on the case
you know how many individual shootings
happened in chicago over the weekend
66. there was one officer involved
shooting here because a man resisted
arrest
and reached into his car when they told
him not to
at the very last minute there's one of
those in kenosha 66 shootings in chicago
not a word
they don't seem to be monitoring that
they don't seem to be looking very
closely at that
because they don't give a damn they
don't care if one of these people dies
or if all of these people die
it's not about that at all lori
lightfoot
does not lose one second sleep over the
killing
or nice was not killing the shooting of
this guy mr blake
it's just a tool and it's amazing
because
there are still some conservatives who
don't see it so they feel really
pressured to prove to these
awful democrats you know that they're
not racist and they said black lives
matter it's terrible there's a scourge
of
of police brutality where racist white
supremacists are
gunning down all these innocent black
men that isn't happening
this is this is a cynical strategy
being implemented for the election
you're going to see this go away after
november 3rd
you'll it'll crop up again i mean these
things happen but it's not going to be a
major news story and it goes so much
further than the shootings
right now there's a group of black
professors in universities
who are demanding the abolition of
english
the language the english language white
mainstream english is how they describe
it
a subcommittee of an organization called
the conference on college composition
and communication
named itself why we can't breathe that's
the subcommittee they published a list
of demands
calling for the abolition of white
mainstream english
to make way for black linguistic justice
that's the new one i i thought that
these
euphemisms couldn't get crazier after uh
after julian castro during the 2020
democratic presidential primary
called for reproductive justice for
trans women meaning men who can't have
children but they
basically called for abortions for men
using all this cockamamie language with
the word justice but we've gotten a
little
black linguistic justice what is that
well the first issue you might see here
is that when we refer to white
mainstream english as a terrible thing
you might recall that english is not
just a language english is also
a people known for that language and the
english people are very very white
so you can't you cannot separate
the history of the english language from
white people because the english are
white
but i suppose this is a great injustice
that the english are white
the english should have looked different
than the english do six authors include
a michigan state professor
a cal state professor cal state
fullerton cal state always goes really
far left on these things
a boston university professor texas
christian university professor
and a university of alabama at
birmingham scholar here's the statement
in case you've forgotten what we mean
when we say black lives matter
we stand with the words of the three
radical black organizers and freedom
fighters dreamers quote unquote
alicia garza patrice calors and opal
temeti
who created the historic political
project black lives matter those are
explicitly the three
women who are self-described trained
marxists
you so you saw that video of uh patrice
calors
coming out and saying yeah me and alicia
were trained marxists then you saw
photos of opal tometti smiling with the
communist dictator of venezuela
among among other communist provocations
this is all part of a plan the plan is
to undermine western civilization we
said earlier the police were standing
for american law well here white
mainstream english is a stand-in
for the the very method of communication
the very idea
that we can have objective communication
they they go for language on the left
they focus on it with political
correctness they focus on it with cancel
culture they focus on it here with the
abolition of english
for for one reason if you can talk to
one another across
racial groups sexual groups national
group if you can speak to one another
then you can have objective conversation
and debate
the only way you and i can communicate
right now is because there is an
objective reality outside of me and you
that we are using symbols called words
and letters to refer to
so we can use our faculties of reason
which perceive objective reality
to discuss that thing and try to get a
closer handle on it
if the left wants to destroy that kind
of politics that authentic politics
self-government debate they've got to
destroy
language which they have been trying to
do now for at least 100 years
and which these authors who i suspect
are somewhat intelligent
and somewhat educated they know exactly
what they're doing because they're not
even just using the slogan which a lot
of
squishy people who are ignorant of the
subject say they say black lives matter
they don't know that it's
a radical marxist group these professors
calling for the abolition of english
are naming the marxists they know
exactly what they're doing
that's the point that's the point unless
you need
just a a cherry on top of this
proof that the democrats don't care a
wit about racial justice
and that all of this is just about
burning down the country for the
election
joe biden just picked up an endorsement
of the most
well-known self-described
white identitarian which you'd call the
most clear
white racist in the country richard
spencer
richard spencer who they always peg on
trump even though he doesn't support
trump has now endorsed joe biden the
media has gone completely quiet over it
we will
we will get to what that means in just a
second we will get to the rnc which
kicked off last night
first though i've got to thank you thank
you for subscribing
to the michael show youtube channel we
appreciate it it's good to give ben
you know those clicks and stuff on the
daily wire youtube channel but frankly
for me i consider it
really wonderful when you go over to
michael nola show youtube channel also
we're going to be covering the rnc
tonight you can hang out with drew
clavin he's going to be giving his
all-access view of the rnc i will be
doing that later in the week and then
we'll have
a backstage where we can all chat about
it and argue and laugh at the rnc
so we can we can do that later and head
on over right now if you are not an
all-access member that is our top tier
of membership
if you subscribe you will get not one
but two leftist years tumblers
you get to chat with us the hosts and
the writers and the whole team and then
all the other alexis members
in the all access in the discussions we
have a great time doing it
plus you'll get 20 off right now go to
dailywire.com
knowles canon wlas use the code access
you get 20
off and not one but two leftist years
tumblers we will
get to the white identitarian
endorsement of joe biden
we will get to the rnc stick around for
a lot more
richard spencer the well-known white
identitarian endorses joe biden he
tweets out quote
i plan to vote for biden and a straight
democratic ticket
it's not based on accelerationism or
anything like that the liberals are
clearly
more competent people the word
acceleration is we actually mentioned it
a little bit
maybe a week ago it refers to this
marxist concept
about the acceleration of contradictions
within the capitalist system within our
traditional system that basically
the seeds of our civilization are are
built in
uh the seeds of our own destruction are
built in and so eventually you're going
to see these contradictions and
the civilization is going to collapse uh
this is occasionally picked up sometimes
ironically or tongue-in-cheek
by a various other groups who are not
explicitly marxist
in this case it's this white
identitarian who's referring to
uh presumably he's referring to this
acceleration specifically on racial
grounds but he's saying it's actually
not that
in other words he's not going to vote
for biden so that things get way
worse and then the whole system will
collapse and will either become marxist
or will become
fascist will become we'll go back to the
feudal ages or
what it's not what he's saying he's
saying i'm voting for the democrats
because they're more competent people
more competent what does that mean
we're saying the nation doesn't burn
down under democrats
this is the same argument that joe biden
has been making right joe biden
when the country was being lit on fire a
few months ago for the for the first
time this cycle
he said we can't take four more years of
this that was a threat
who's doing the burning it's not
republicans it's not it's not white
supremacists it's not
the democrats are doing the burning and
antifa and black lives matter
and they're saying look vote for us and
we'll stop burning the country down
and i actually think that's what spencer
is seeing here he says look the country
doesn't burn when democrats are in
charge
now it's an extortion racket is what's
what the democrats are doing
but he says yeah whatever and he doesn't
have any particular love for
for donald trump because donald trump's
not a white identitarian no matter what
the mainstream media try to say about
him next time they call
trump the candidate of the racists the
white identitarians whatever
and make sure you remind them that
richard spencer just unironically
endorsed joe biden so who's endorsing
donald trump who's speaking the rnc
kicked off
they got a big long speaker lineup i'll
give i'll give some thoughts on the rnc
generally but they did have some big
winners here
one of whom uh we spoke to i was it was
either on
my show or i may have been filling over
ben shapiro's show
but i spoke to mark mccloskey he's the
uh one half of the gun couple in st
louis that defended their lives and
property when an armed mob
broke through their gates and threatened
them and you'll remember he was wearing
that pink polo shirt
and those white chinos and i felt he
should be on the next
brooks brothers catalog cover where
they're probably not going to put him
there so he
and his wife the mccloskeys went out and
they gave a rousing speech at the rnc
take a listen
america is such a great country that not
only do you have the right to own a gun
and use it to defend yourself but
thousands of americans
will offer you free advice on how to use
it at least that's what we
experienced what you saw happen to us
could just as easily happen to any of
you who are watching from quiet
neighborhoods
around our country and that's what we
want to speak to you
about tonight that's exactly right
whether it's the defunding of police
ending cash bails or criminals can be
released
back out on the streets the same day to
riot again
or encouraging anarchy and chaos on our
streets
it seems as if the democrats no longer
view the government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens
not a single person in the out of
control mob you saw at our house
was charged with a crime but you know
who was
we were we were this was a
very very effective speech this this was
one of if not the most effective speech
during the whole
convention why it opened up with humor
right you saw the woman she goes
listen when you when you become a
national uh
viral sort of superstar because the mob
comes after you
uh you'll get a lot of people giving you
advice some of them are giving you
advice on how to hold a gun because
people were making fun of them for
brandishing their weapons all over the
place it was funny
it contained a legitimate warning for
what's going on right now
and it focused on the leftist inversion
of justice what a great tool at the end
there he says
the marauding criminals who broke under
my property weren't thrown in jail you
know who they're threatening to throw in
jail me
and by the way if they're threatening
throw me in jail they're threatening to
throw you in jail
i loved this i love the choice of having
them speak a more cautious convention
would not have had them speak
because they're just regular people
right they're just people
who are we only know their names because
the mob both
in the literal physical mob and then the
online mob came for them one day
but this is what the gop has got to do
they've got to point to
to regular old people and by the way
that doesn't mean a certain class of
people or a certain race of people the
mccloskeys are very very wealthy it's
actually part of why they were targeted
in the first place
by the mob doesn't matter we can all
identify with the mccloskeys
because they're not known for their
wealth what they're known for
is the mob coming after them and the rnc
giving a voice to those kinds of people
who feel
that no one's speaking for them whether
they're a zillionaire or whether they're
a factory worker when they're being come
out unjustly
that is a very effective strategy you
know the democrats learned a little bit
or the republicans rather learned a
little bit from the democrats from their
convention
which was super produced and and it just
didn't work it was very boring so the
republicans for most of the speeches had
people just come up to a podium
give a speech but they didn't learn
enough because the speeches first of all
didn't have a crowd so it sounded kind
of weird they'd give these rousing lines
and then nobody's applauding
and they were a little too divorced from
reality and they were a little too
polished
and they they weren't ah they weren't
speaking in many ways
to the issues that we've got right now
but some some were i mean some some
moments where we're not going to go
through every single speech
and you know obviously everybody out
here is trying to do their best job the
republicans are trying to
go out there and and uh win the election
so i i want to just focus on people that
you might not have heard the mccloskeys
for one and then uh this this
great guy maximo alvarez maximo alvarez
uh who comes out he's another guy you
probably haven't heard of
and he speaks about his experience uh
his perspective from outside of america
than
looking into america at the democratic
ticket
there's no place to hide speaking to you
today because president trump
may not always be politically correct
he's in fact
a successful businessman your average
career politician
our president is just another family man
a friend
and most important our elected
commander-in-chief who puts america
first
keep in mind the other guy running for
president is mostly concerned about
power
yes yes power for them
but not for the benefit of all americans
i'm speaking to you today because
i have seen people like this before i've
seen movements like this before
i've seen ideas like this before
and i am here to tell you we cannot let
them
take over our country you've seen it
before what's he referring to is
referring to fidel castro
he's referring to these people who
are now openly campaigning in the name
of marxism
even though we thought they were just
liberals but but many of them now are
openly campaigning in the name of
marxism
and in the name of marxists and he calls
it out people like to see that
we all like to see our kind of favorite
political celebrities that
there's sometimes that's interesting but
much much more important
this year we we just want to see people
speaking the truth
when he says that the democrats are
running to get more power in a way this
is like a truism right because
people run for office to have power to
do things but he says but they're not
they're not interested in using power
for the benefit of all americans
and that's true that's undeniably true
whether you think trump is
good at using power or not it seems
clear to me
he is exercising power for all americans
one of the few themes he comes back to
again and again is
we all bleed the same blood of patriots
we all need to have national loyalty we
all need to be able to speak our minds
in public because it's the only way we
can have self-government the only way we
can have unity
and what do the democrats say they say
black people can never get ahead in
america you should burn down cities we
shouldn't be peaceful
some some of the politicians and i say
by the way only some
are still calling for people remaining
peaceful
others are not do you remember when uh
when chris cuomo
uh fredo cuomo on cnn said
show me where it says that assemblies
have to be peaceful you say well it's in
the constitution first of all that's
where it's
right there in the first amendment but
even openly on cnn saying yeah maybe you
can be violent maybe it's a good thing
to be violent
sean king saying go out there be violent
hillary clinton saying you can't be
civil with people
who disagree with you right but listen
maxine waters saying go mob republicans
where you see them wherever you see them
in the streets
they're saying go out there when we win
we're going to be good for our people
and bad for your people republicans
you don't this is not an issue where the
two sides are
are equal here this is an issue where
one side
says they want to help all americans the
other side said
they only want to help they only want to
help democrats so what do they do they
try to burn down the country
they try to delegitimize the election
they've got all these cockamamie
conspiracy theories about the post
office
the democrats who are trying to steal
the election
through widespread mail-in ballots are
now saying that republicans are trying
to steal the election by
defunding the post office that they just
gave 10 billion dollars to the
postmaster general
louis de joy just came out tried to pour
some water on these conspiracy theories
as part of this conversation there are
many inaccuracies about my actions that
i wish to again
correct first i did not direct the
removal of blue collection boxes
or the removal of mail processing
equipment
second i did not direct the cutback on
hours at any of our postal
post offices and finally i did not
direct the elimination or
any cutback in overtime
i did however suspend these practices to
to remove any misperceptions about our
commitment
to delivering the nation's election mail
any further assertions by the media or
elected officials
is furthering a false narrative to the
american people
of course of course that's the case but
the left doesn't care
they're gonna i don't think that they're
pushing conspiracy theories because they
think they true
they're true i don't think they're
pushing conspiracy theories because they
even know that they're false i think
they're pushing conspiracy theories
because they just don't care
and they're more than willing to burn
down the country or threaten to burn
down our body politic
to win an election and they just don't
care and they're just going to do it
that's the threat
what do we call this kind of violence
against
metaphorical violence against our
political system and literal violence in
the streets what do we call it
the word that keeps cropping up is
senseless you always hear senseless
violence
whenever it suits a narrative right now
let's take it all the way to the
religious level we always
quote henry cardinal manning on this
show who said that at bottom all
conflict is theological
right now throughout the west churches
are being burned down
right now on earth christians are the
most persecuted religious group
in the world right now people are being
attacked at churches
this just happened in philadelphia
philly police department
is trying to find a woman who hit a
female elector in the face
during a sunday morning novus ordo mass
in the cathedral basilica
of saints peter and paul this is a
catholic mass someone comes up it sucks
the woman in the face
the philadelphia archbishop nelson perez
says
during the 11am mass which was broadcast
live
via my facebook page in archdiocese and
vimeo channel
a senseless act of aggression took place
one of the lectures was punched by
someone in the congregation she left the
altar
senseless act of aggression is it
senseless
the people who are perpetrating this
violence are
trying to bring about senselessness
they're trying to bring about a politics
a culture and a religious world in which
we can't
debate anything where language itself is
taken from us where we can't refer to
objective reality
where there is said to be no such thing
as objective truth only your truth and
my
truth and my feelings and my oppression
and my passions that i'm going to vent
by burning down the country
they're trying to affect senselessness
but the way in which they're trying to
do that is highly sensible
highly reasonable highly logical they
know
that they cannot win in in a traditional
debate
in a in a traditional discussion in
traditional self-government
so they're trying to burn down the
edifice we should be highly sensitive to
that plan
to that tactic that that is
a real strategy and unless we wake up to
the logic of that strategy
we're going to lose logic and reason and
sensible political debate
and then we're going to lose our
self-government that's what they're
trying to push for it's only going to
get worse
until november 3rd that's our show let's
hope we can keep it together until then
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
you